[Musique]
je m'appelle jacques et marc l j'ai dix
ans et je suis tranquillement ma plus
grande passion et le club parce que
j'aime me sentir dans la peau d'un
personnage et vivre plusieurs émotions
j'adore voyager car j'aime découvrir de
nouvelles cultures
pendant cette présentation je vais vous
parler du crew chief un projet que j'ai
initiées dans mon école et que nous
avons réalisé l'impact avait déjà vu
cette boîte de lui dans votre quartier
est-ce que ce monstre un piqué votre
curiosité avec ses couleurs vives si oui
il fait déjà de quoi je vais vous parler
sauf si mon projet le cros cliff le
croque l'iss un projet qui rendent de
plus en plus au québec
vous pouvez en trouver dans les écoles
les garderies ou mamie parc en plus
depuis 2007 nous avons accueilli un
croquelivres aux patients 5 gonzague le
concept s'inspire de la proche bras ou
donna lee c'est un réseau de bois de
partage de livres destiné aux jeunes
âgés de 0 à 12 ans du québec
c'est en septembre 2014 que le premier
croquis ennemis leur objectif est de
promouvoir le plaisir de la lecture
si vous voulez participer à mon projet
vous devez prendre livre que vous ne
lisez plus vous pouvez aller déposer à
l'intérieur et choisir un livre de votre
choix
bon mon projet seulement donc pour lui
les livres c'est sa nourriture
alors qu'en temps d'épouser un d'encre
au clic vous le nourrissez et fait
dévorer ses livres à votre tour
moi j'ai eu l'idée de crock livres en
promenant le tout avec mon père et ma
mère on est passé devant une école et
ils avaient 7 bordry j'ai demandé ce que
c'était et ma mère m'a tout expliqué le
lendemain j'en ai parlé avec mon ami
margerie et on ne trouvait que c'était
une belle initial
si à implanter dans notre école alors on
le présentait à notre professeur de
quatre imams et madame arief pilotes et
une the égale faire le croque laisser
mon projet partie économique
ce à quoi aider des familles compass
d'argent pour s'acheter des livres neufs
parce que dans mon projet il des livres
gratuits et usagers dans ces familles
leurs peuvent se procurer un grand
nombre de livres gratuitement
ça prend aussi le partage pas ce que lui
procure sunshine de partage de lits et
des coulées vais déposer d'un creux
cliff ce n'est plus le sien mais c'est
celui du monstre
bon dit économique y apprend que partage
mais aussi écologique
au lieu de laisser ton livre traîner
dans ta bibliothèque ne jamais lire ou
même de le jeter du palais le déposer
dans mon projet et je suis certaine que
quelqu'un va être très contente de
pouvoir le lire moi le croque les samo
fait grandir en tant que personne
parce que j'ai vu comment sera lise le
projet de a à z et ça me donne envie de
plus m'impliquer dans ma communauté que
ce soit en faisant des projets en
m'impliquant à plusieurs communautés ou
en faisant des activités parascolaires
j'espère que je vous ai donné envie de
vous impliquer dans votre communauté
comme moi et qui sait peut-être même par
ce projet à votre tour merci
[Applaudissements]